foi no quieto e eu tenho 10 anos de
idade
ultimamente eu venho pensando como a
extinção de um animal pode prejudicar a
nossa vida aqui na terra
bom eu vou começar falando sobre a terra
que é a nossa casa a gente divide cela
com outros milhões de milhões de animais
mas o ser humano está fazendo com que
esses animais que vivem com a gente isso
mão antes da hora deles
primeiro eu vou falar sobre os gigantes
desaparecidos um exemplo deles é o
dinossauro que na é na hipótese mais
aceitável disse que o meteoro caiu na
terra poeira subiu as plantas não
conseguiu fazer fotossíntese e assim
eles morreram
a gente não teve culpa disso foi uma
mudança muito brusca do ambiente que
eles viviam
outro exemplo são os gigantes do gelo ou
a grande fauna que viviam perfeitamente
no lugar dele estava tudo congelado de
boa até que o gelo começou a corrigir
descongelar muito rápido eles não
estavam adaptados pra cá e aí eles
morreram não foi nossa culpa
mas qual a nossa culpa na extinção de
animais é de alguns animais odor por
exemplo ele vivia perfeitamente adaptado
no local até que o segundo chegou
começou a matar tanto mas tanto do dow
que não tinha mais nada para ser morto e
assim eles sumiram por nossa culpa por
exemplo o maçarico se morre que ele é um
bom exemplo de como a extinção uma coisa
recente
após que eu posso estar falando de um
animal sendo extinto porque ele fez 20 e
2013 isso não faz muito tempo e também
não somente os animais que se extinguem
algumas plantas que poderiam ser vos
medicinais para criar a cura para
doenças como a como câncer ou aids são
extintas e assim a gente não tem mais
cura pra isso
as baleias estão sendo mortas no mar
pelos navios japoneses a barreira de
corais tais branco que sendo graças ao
aquecimento global causado pelo homem e
os peixes que se reproduziam lá vão
morrer e os une os outros peixes que
comiam eles também vão morrer
o mico leão dourado mesmo entrando e
saindo da lista de animais ameaçados de
extinção ainda está sendo quase sentindo
um besouro que você nem conhecia pode
estar sendo extinto e também um furo que
você não sabe o nome também pode
esse distinto e como que a gente pode
ajudar bombs leis pessoas estão tentando
ajudar mas comparado à população mundial
são muito poucas
veja o seu redor da escola seu trabalho
um parque quando você joga lixo ali você
vai está prejudicando o ambiente de um
animal assim o animal que vivia lá
promete vai morrer
outros animais ou morrer e como a gente
não vai dar a adaptar deputado é esse
local
a gente vai morrer causando a extinção
do ser humano espero que tenha entendido
obrigado